salut aujourd'hui on est jeudi le jeudi
je fais des choses un petit peu
différente je parle de ce que je veux
alors on va parler d'argent l'argent et
d'énigmes j'ai une énigme à vous
soumettre
évidemment il y aura la solution à la
fin de la vidéo n'y allez pas tout de
suite cette énigme c'est avant tout une
histoire c'est l'histoire de trois amis
ils sont autour d'une table et hiddink
chacun manche tu veux chacun bois ce
qu'il veut à la fin du repas ils
demandent la note et la date est de 25
euros en clair ils n'ont pas déjeuné
dans une brasserie à paris à la limite
dans un kebab et encore ils ont pas pris
de frites les trois amis mettent chacun
10 euros sur la table il sort tous les
trois un billet 10 et mettent chacun 10
euros sur la table a service passe elle
encaisse les trouviez de 10 elle ramène
pièces de 5 euros parce qu'elle est
maligne en restauration une technique
pour avoir un pourboire
c'est de ne pas ramener un billet mais
de casser le billet en pièces donc c'est
ce qu'elle fait allez mali et elle a
bien raison la serveuse parce que ça
fonctionne chacun des trois amis
récupère une pièce de 1 euro dont il
récupère un euro chacun sur les 5 euros
il reste donc deux euros sur la table et
ils décident d'un commun accord de les
laisser en pourboire à la serveuse kit
malien a été très sympathique et ça ça
me pose un problème non pas que c'est
pas bien dessin pour voir ça c'est pas
ceux ci mais si on calcule ils ont
chacun donné à billet de 10 euros ils
ont chacun récupérer un euro donc ça
fait 9 euros chacun jusque là ça va ils
ont été 3 faire exactement la même chose
donc trois fois 9,27 euros plus les deux
euros de la serveuse ça nous fait 27
plus de 29 euros ils sont passés où les
1 euros manquants 27 plus de 29 alors
qu'il ya 30 euros débarqué trois billets
où sont passés les 1 euro un billet 10
avec une pièce de 1 récupérer ça fait 9
euros x 3 27 luce les deux jours de la
serveuse 29 il manque un euro et à
priori ils sont pas sous la table je
vous laisse chercher c'est une ligne que
je connais depuis longtemps qui m'a
toujours amusé la réponse sera la toute
fin de la vidéo comme ça si vous ne
voulez pas la regarder tout de suite ne
la regardez pas vous pouvez chercher à
la faire vous pouvez aussi poser
l'énigme à d'autres personnes si ce
format un petit peu différent vous a plu
vous pouvez me le faire savoir simon 15
euros faut pas qu'il manque un pouce en
l'air par contre si vous commenter je
voulais je vous réponds vous pouvez
aussi vous abonner à la chaîne si vous
décidez de ne pas regarder la réponse à
leurs rendez vous demain à 17 heures
pour le prochain mentale blog ciao
c'est
alors ils sont passés où c'est un euro
parce qu'on les a vraiment perdu en fait
on n'a pas perdu les 1 euro
mathématiquement parlant ce que je vous
ai dit n'est pas logique
ils ont payé 25 euros de ropa ça c'est
sûr et certain puisque la note était de
25 euros comme ils ont laissé deux euros
pour voir la serveuse
ça fait 27 25 + 2 c'est ce qu'ils ont
vraiment dépenser tous les trois ils ont
récupéré les trois euros il ya une pièce
chacun ça fait bien les 30 euros c'était
une erreur de calcul de fer 27 +2
puisque dans les vingt-sept y avait déjà
les deux euros de pourboire peut-être
vous avez déjà trouvé par vous même
c'est pas évident à trouver donc si
c'est le cas bravo si c'est pas le cas
c'est normal en attendant prenez soin de
vous et rendez vous demain 17h pour le
prochain mentale vlog ciao